la raison pour laquelle vous gesticulez
beaucoup sur la définition des
événements
qui ont répliqué aux meurtres de Naël
c'est parce que vous ne voulez pas qu'on
parle du meurtre de Naël c'est
précisément pour effacer le fait
générateur que vous en faites des tonnes
à l'extrême droite et je dirais même
plus que vous voulez effacer votre
propre responsabilité
dans une certaine culture
raciste qui existe notamment dans
certains syndicats dans le ministre de
la ministère de l'Intérieur
une culture de l'impunité car le racisme
est un délit et de la même façon qu'un
policier
qui vole est un ripoux un policier
raciste est un ripoux et aucun d'entre
nous ne peut tenir que la police
républicaine est dans son sein des
éléments ripoux vous utilisez n'importe
quel prétexte pour venir vomir votre
haine de la police c'est ça la réalité
vous utilisez n'importe quel prétexte
pour venir justifier les émeutes
vous dites que nous n'avons pas parlé de
la mort de ce jeune garçon bien sûr
qu'on en parle mais vous vous faites
vous justifiez les émeutes par ce décès
cette justification elle est
inadmissible quelle que soit la raison
on ne brûle pas les commissariats on
attaque pas les forces de l'ordre on ne
brûle pas les véhicules des personnes
qui travaillent on ne s'attaque pas aux
écoles on ne brûle pas un bus qui vient
pour faire du dépistage du cancer du
sein des femmes d'accord voilà quand
vous aurez intérêt ça alors vous aurez
retrouvé votre place effectivement dans
la République